now to exclusive reporting from cbs news
and the washington post about attempts
to overturn the 2020 election and keep
president trump in office
conservative activist jenny thomas she's
the wife of supreme court justice
clarence thomas was texting about that
effort with then white house chief of
staff mark meadows the messages
highlight the extraordinarily close ties
between the trump white house and mrs
thomas chief election and campaign
correspondent robert costa obtained some
of those messages along with bob
woodward from the washington post robert
good morning to you i read your report
last night and let's just say some of
those text messages are raising a lot of
eyebrows and dropping a lot of jaws
that's exactly right good morning gail
the messages do reveal a back channel
conversation between jenny thomas and
mark meadows a top aide to president
trump just as he was vowing to fight his
election loss all the way to the supreme
court
so we'll be going to the u.s supreme
court a day before joe biden was
declared the winner of the 2020 election
the wife of supreme court justice
clarence thomas texted president trump's
top aide do not concede the next week
ginny thomas told him america's
constitutional governance is at the
precipice and alleged biden in the left
is attempting the greatest heist of our
history
meadows responded i will stand firm we
will fight until there is no fight left
thanks for all you do
the messages are among more than 2300
trump's chief of staff turned over to
the congressional january 6 committee
investigating the insurrection 29 of
them were exchanged between meadows and
jenny thomas and on november 24th
meadows texted thomas that ensuring
trump's win was a fight of good versus
evil thomas replied thank you needed
that this plus a conversation with my
best friend just now
it's unclear whom jenny thomas meant
her husband has called her this a gift
from god and my totally best friend in
the whole world in other texts jenny
thomas repeated false conspiracy
theories and urged meadows to make
conservative lawyer sydney powell who
was spreading controversial claims
president trump won by a landslide the
public face of president trump's defense
thomas told meadows pal is getting
inundated with evidence of fraud urging
him to release the kraken and save us
from the left taking america down
[Music]
in last january after briefly attending
president trump's stop the steel rally
on january 6
thomas turned her anger on vice
president mike pence who refused to
block the certification of the election
texting meadows we are living through
what feels like the end of america most
of us are disgusted with the vp
she then went on to say those who
attacked the capitol are not
representative of our great teams of
patriots for donald trump
cbs news reached out repeatedly to jenny
thomas and her husband justice thomas
who was hospitalized recently for
comment but we have not heard back jenny
thomas has publicly stated there is no
conflict of interest between her
activism and her husband's position in
the only case related to january 6 that
made it to the supreme court so far
eight of the justices supported
releasing president trump's records to
the committee the only dissenting voice
was justice thomas
robert thank you very much